where you are going is just as important
as how you plan to get there as we look
forward to new frontiers here on earth
and beyond places where resources may be
scarce or non-existent we need to look
for new ways to carry ourselves beyond
the horizon ways like sailing on
currents of air drawing energy from the
Rays of the Sun everything I do is the
example I received from my grandfather
and my father my grandfather made the
first flight in the stratosphere
actually he was the first man to witness
with his own eyes the curvature of the
earth my father went to the bottom of
the Mariana Trench 11 kilometers down
the deepest spot in the ocean I thought
it was normal to explore and for a long
time
exploration was about discovering new
geographical territories I believe that
now exploration has a role to play if we
want to make a better world in the 30
years ago we had this idea to fly around
the world without the dependence on
fossil energy they told us it was
impossible so that was the starting
point
Solar Impulse is a feat of exploration
it's a scientific adventure the goal was
to demonstrate how you can use solar
energy to fly around the world it was
not possible to take an existing
airplane and to grow some solar cells it
would never work
so if we think this happened completely
from scratch the conclusion was to build
an airplane the size of a 747 with the
weight of a car the only airplane today
which can fly almost forever
and these technologies can be used
everywhere not just in our airplane and
this moment of rapture where you let
behind what you know and enter into the
unknown now it's the leap of faith 2016
Solar Impulse became the first aircraft
in aviation history the circumnavigate
the globe with no fuel if you want
exploration very often you need to get
out of the system because the system is
paralyzed by common assumptions it's not
the people selling candles to invented
the light bulb
[Music]
we've succeeded to use solar energy to
fly around the world it's interesting to
see the difference between conquering
and exploring when you want to conquer
it's to have more when you want to
explore it's to know more the future
will be very different so you need an
explorer's mind if you want to succeed
in the future
[Music]